the mechanics of throwing a baseball I
cannot think of anything more difficult
to do under pressure you do it so well I
watched every single one of the World
Series games and I was thinking you
almost got to be a different kind of
person what kind of kid were you when
you were a kid and you were pitching how
soon did you know like this is what I'm
supposed to be doing this is something
I'm really good at um you know I threw
pretty hard when I was younger but in
Little League I was a little wild you
know I think I I ended a couple careers
early I you know there's there's there's
this one instance I can remember that
there was a there was a kid in Little
League who was first at bat
I threw it you know pretty hard and I
hit him in the head yeah you didn't mean
to
I didn't mean to of course um so he
didn't like that too much his second
time up I'm still pitching and he's on
deck kind of crying and and you know his
mom and mom and dad like it's okay you
know go go up there to be frightened and
then I hit him in the other head you're
kidding no wow you're missing in
completely different directions yeah
that kid was never to be hurt or seen
from again yeah well he's a soprano
it's a beautiful high singing voice it's
hard to know you don't know what that
kid could have gone on to do maybe he's
a tech billionaire now maybe he's done
something better let's think that let's
think that let's not think that he spent
the rest of his life I would just think
how old were you then ten nine ten nine
ten and you were throwing how fast you
think you were tall gosh I have no idea
hundred
okay sure yeah yeah cuz he used to throw
the ball after you were pushed out of a
catapult yeah cookie the year that knew
who's that I remember that I remember
that yeah
you